аджику та мої but i про свято в Україні та
чим удачі вам з викл і на чому вчилася
готелі покоління нині потрібно зміню це
так вже про ралі та реформи освіти
андська гаузе сьогоднішня наша розмова
або програма ралі з міністром та святі
науки україни або navi читаємо вас на
буковині джеррі то їх та й вас і всіх
для дачі
з почином і сьогоднішній наш розмив
сина вигодою нового початкового уроку
зналися дискусії
то ще один з почту webmin його червоний
ручки домашнє завдання для початку б і
школи та за проводи la ville не канікули
середовище ж активно говорити з встиг
ного результату чека та
міністерства і чому сама таки 0 до дня з
правильного в один біт більше не штреки
у парижі сили та навколо ланцюгового на день
їжі ці міфи
давайте раз точно його стілець і що
повішеного в дині від суеца підкови та
школи і я думаю що все бути крики моїх
дітей у по четкой в ​​школі я так вже 4
початкова школа yt порозумітися що повз
йому такий по і один щур качана ви і
школи та школи в цілому я б назвала
знання у та південь руду тому що жити idef
перед дуже багато інформації і ми пішли
повстанемо та рукам та шляхом що ми з ebay
ший більше термінології та різьблених знань
за сува йому від шкільної програми
результаті йди ти пішов і лікаря ти
раниш і інтерес був навчання раніше
чув стейсі майкла заразу ж до
третій четвертий geht es не
погіршуються на цьому етапі і найважливіше
що порив від своїх програм початкова і
школи продуманий суворо у нас нібито вид
побачите програми віковим із кута
владі учень там уми раз виходило
хлопець виду програм самої початку ви і
школи типу що ви сказали
цілі такі у гвинтівки рекомендації донів
чайна вихідного процесів за чіткою в
школі на стрибати сюди домашнє завдання
залі нічого нового не вигадував і
тому що я держави та санітарні норми
по домашніх домашніх завданнях та інтервал
асті
ми вище нагадали і процес норми вчителям
тому що завдання тамтешні по-перше
класах і раніше так уже не було передачі
на в іншому класі ви але точно може
100 новий ти більше не їж прямо на ви
значен відривалися години тридцяти хвалим
путіна у третьому класі сорок п'ять
хвилин і ден і що нажаль
пийте вчить або забуває проти
санітарні норми та
янкул і домашні завдання задається так ти
не така я десь за аліш перед великою
доля батька
що дитинка сама не можеш впоратися зі
своїм домашнім завданням
оце за галі можеш зал і shit i just in
у дітей великих бочки з тисячі найкращих
причин немає допомагають ебру б ти з
домашні завдання знову тут на маргіні
си іван і не будуть встик а ти там у ми
за кликав іосиф чат або фактичного
ікона ось ці норми
ручки і простого ліфті дурімо і ціни ми
вигадали
все про виднілася не системи про
цілитель над ним я комод його вати дітей
даунів джоанна я газу догляд це їх безодня
ванну ідеальністю
і тим щоб не видно кошару від ремували
родись вони відривалися страх так ось
психолог і говорити про те штуку і
маленько дітей на бездоріжжя іп ісатай
етель кайф читайте до сформованості у
її новачок писання ми на відразу мило
рубатиму і пога тупо крейда і ось шкіра
nappa маркою окуеть рибаль крісло ось і
а ви про бленду водиться рубає і боготол
а їм коди що у нас модно виривати і
старовині і переписувати ще раз у мережі
нас правді стрес всякі на шируються
у дітей на його на бійця помийтеся і нас
правді процес навчання твоєї процес
проходження через повненькою ти маєш
право на полицю і ти не винен
адже ти їй допоміг чи відриву від стрес
du das формування новачок харчування bi ти
можеш писати простим вулицям і до етиру
tyreese і на вузьку смужку і виправляти
і як що heine виправлення тація телицю
нормально від ручку ти відриваєш як ви
на місті до ліфта без формування новачки
опис написання так ось особа
адаптаційного періоду саме так ми
називаємо у перший клас
ми про пуну йому в 4-му не ви хрестову
ти червону ручку і за крісло немає
черв'яну ручку і взяли проби ну йому в
4-ом ви вирішив цю саму істину я ким
кольором води виставлятимуть оцінки
пішло будиночках і у саші то хучні
the same живуть а елена і чорної ж ніби
і хочу вам сказати ще яйця чи методики
за погіршення дітей d4 та наприклад
зелене ручку і піт крісло скелі пливу в
далі фрагменти роботи дитинки що
здалося що c ти написав на та пак
успішно щось вся педагогіка і dh ляхум
не корані про мотивацію вона поки що
уникнення мотивації це дуже важливо для
civic дітей
посилиш розуміє ще сидить і призначай
на динамічніше нас цифрові розрив
маленькими дітьми і в 4-му столітті їх наш
цар сидить із прямо і ту ж багату
інформацією з тим, щоб не зустрічає інтерес
почалося з епохи мб значиться на
загальна муза його хочу не дано вч вони
там у праведніше у світ не системи
процідити над ним mia карате а я кому ти
висновок та і
і ми не за раз парі орендувати
українську школу на формування не на
пихова не тільки знань вона формування
стику їх
річці у їх competed маскою батька та знання
вміння та цінності
через заки ти намагаєшся так че і наші
душі та духовні ситуації критично
переосмисливши і їжте більше немає
знання там і що з травня потім допомагати
нашим дітям ви вирішу ось і як же києву
таки профі стіні проблем ще до нового і
до нинішнього початкова урок столітті
назвала на пак і з крабом і і на ebay
шлюпки дні ми сьогодні і для усвяти
ну нас правді ми предметно зайнялися про
дільничних шкіл часу було на справити
малу
тому що літні місяці два місяці ми
замість був ці програми на відкриту
платформу
це
ера і вранці він і над висимо з
половиною тисяч коментарів та 4000
авторизованих дуб та совок
c свічки тільки пробна про тещу мети
реально проблема і буду в 4 практиці
голки наук вівці іп посмішкою і був і
граматики та активісти тупцювати живі
обговорення ми за вишилася а в межах
того самого державного стандарту cirque
самі підручника і за 1 справа за 4-м
і икарі онукам та початкових за кладемо
щоб он і
трійня лисиці ми з мінами щоб він і
прогулювалася цю мету змін і щоб
Тясмин і торкнуло сяк, що набили кільку з
цієї з приводу старші школи у нас
зради про програму з історії України
тому що ціну вигляд не адобо
історії ми так активно її пиж і зовсім
слави в sims встиг ство ражева йому
ми живемо про революцію видно step ідеї на
сході
агресії Російської Федерації крим
анексований її на закон про просвітила в
історії більше так вже у води та історії
кримських татар метою будуть вже мало ви
світлана в наших підручних їх історії
а загалом і на меті йому освитян на
переосмислення краще муминів чаєм і
дітей в українській школі вивчаю що
цілковитий випити шлях ми зараз ви клали та для
обмови не я так і публічні документ
концепцію нової української школи та мету
документ просту нову людського ви ж
називається раз за видом і protection травня
вид різанина ти знову українська школа
вид традицій маяцький акуми моєму за раз
владно такий умову яко доступно тому
що в серці нас правді описано в
проекті закону про святий акрил і жити у
парламенті алиш людям ваш купи то ти
закони там розум і ви вирішили встигніть тема
вас вид з тусується широкого голосу
спірс тва і для нас важливо його що вся
реформа була 53 манасу spaced вам дуги
навіки що змінюватимуться себе парламент
та партії
політика та міністри та влада вся реформа
води з успішним в описі ось так було
свого часу сонячними спантеличеними
оцінюванням колиму його закривати жував і
і нас Петро і мало суті чому
міністр табачник
вин би хоч і вс касу вати заміни
натякали винними їх там і щоб увд
мистецтва і зараз для нас важливі вище
акцію реформу його почту виявлялася а
все тому що мета реформи на 10 лиття
я кумарит продовжу ватою і шукай парламент
і її щоку ряди висловила нова
українська школа і до сьогодні концерт все
виставлено в гори не asus пиля стволи
для теж чим наш це я та чим кути відразу
мід і в чому у виднілися
основно нову українську школу видно
нинішній
д від sti
скажімо а там чисто золото серединна q
улюблене відразу мід ще ціну і цілі
дражня яся lets 2
рецепт потрібно зміні бате ми за
розвиваються вам і ап20 польшу ми стільці
кеди душі по хатанаку намагається знань і
інформації школа перестала ніби це
місцях куди git їхнє вудлище бутери метт та
знання та
за раз ти можна інший то в інтернеті за
1 січня електронних ресурсів та шляхи
глави на цих знань душа вали ми duty
променя існуюче таким чином ми вище основі
знання терміни борг у оптового або
свиню програму та наша школа з школа
битий злодії не знати що буде епохи і
творив ці знання на
випробувавши і колими, йому а що їм став ос
треба було сил жити і
то ви є що не так і богу
на тому і мережі lan ейськ арачів у світі
я типу 3 мені з учасники люди не вистачить
першому ставте для того, щоб успішно
самореалізуватися
ціна приклад у міні вчитатися в ставків
жити а то що треба змінив і часто
професія дошка наливатися
мене ніби пити прийнятним і мотив іншого
луддити фінансовою грамотністю
проти ти в команді земними людьми
вміння критично мислить і мати грому
янський соціальної компетентності
яхти та функцію 0 раніше ми людьми та
даєш собі радуй ок ти можеш рубає
обізнаною ви біржу крим аполітичний
вейдер голий ти маєш прийняті рішення
за мій будь не своєї країни культури на
компетентність розуміння владні
ідентичності в серці провалитися
нинішній українській школі нові дениси
при 2 чого а ви але мої but i у новій
школі і ми за розмову йому що
результатом нові школи мої бутони
просто випускники клей на джин інший
сумою дізнайся тема ебу ти хіба не на
особи system і boot і патріот храм 1
поважає ситуацію в дикому і заразному
ходом є і тема ебут і
innovator innovator ціни означає що
винними думками не креативна творча
думки не про ранок усередині до художника
інженеру архітектору наука вівцю ми але
потрібно шкіри і люди не для ви вирішення
владних же кегах та профі сильних
задач і ось так і ми слоні ми можемо
формуватися у диктаторській школі
школі депо ну і кілька і від ми вам даємо
знання а ви по винете знання творить
і я ще наприклад у нас ніколи на вигляд
аліса в традиції не школі в хіба за не
завдання як і ми з іншим способом ніш
загальна прийнято формула та син проблеми
на приклад на сонячному вона за лижним
оцінювання
оцінювати цій печі ще розв'язані
завдання і для назару склала його туре
каплиці члена за лижного оцінювання теж
з місця muse змінилося а тому що як
правило в школі good way to тону що
почім треба
труби це на тому, що ті випробувай
душі увійшли види тени для продовження і
на ступні
кольорові кар'єри dv вона вважатиметься
там у c такі довгі шлях за право
одружуватися та школи в школах новим місцям
на буча ключових компетентностей а
компетентності з я gras знання плюс у
мене плюс цінності на умови до них ви
роботи ставлення та критичному якщо ти як
ставлять і з дотою і через ситуації так
ось наше завдання він у цій замість до і
школи про нову ти методику викладання
ніби за три колишні методики
а щоб дати створені результату проекту
я за розмові нам треба запише
відривалися на планету 12 руки і до давнини
у нас сьогодні у тебе 11 річка в Європі
завищувалася в 3 кошиках російська
федерація Білорусь та Україна
там би про тебе пост роген сказано
його школа почав я налив у думу що б
skoda для здоров'я китай можна з усі /
це кільки за 12 руки і дитину душі 17
руки я красень 6 до 18 полювання за важливі
шов дефіс захисних країн забувати по
музичному середньому світі йдуть 19 руки
так ось дитину сам підсумку
100 ієн на стиль до вилили що вмієте
компетентності сформований його на
чоловіка реально б радий і дали свою
траєкторію дзвонити увагу з практики
скільки у нас зарості випадки екологи ти
пиши на перший курс університету прав
людини і курс це не виявило, що он
з рубіна це правильний вибір підсумку
треба дума ти штору б ти знав опадали
продовжу в цій ціни веж і на вч вони
ти вже вступаємо на бюджет там ще саме
і ви 100 чаю і мені ви завантажуєте їй
підготовкою і в тому числі компетентні см та
і зайна і владні зрілості там у c 12
рік спочатку
яхти буду в частині щоб одразу знятих
вливання часом відразу бочки подумати як
ж у трюм від 1 до 2 17 руки за шкільну
в роті якова ножу свято 3 мою
спеціальному за галину тато цінний ця
школа повторю і я подекуди ось я хочу
щоб сице відразу милою у 1 клас 2 накид
та річкові нові українські школи гіти
піду 18 19 початковому роті
c означає що 12 рік навчання для цілей
дітей війни knit через 11 уроці в
двадцять дев'ятому втратить розуму початковому
роті та зараз esp одягається україна
буду читку стоять вже на вході до
європейського союзу про ціни будуть
тусуватися з усіх дуже стиль колише
рекомендує до школи та 17 18 19
початковому роті то можна було б інший
таєш вище для тіла потрібні ресурси
повз n 112 рік надрукувати школяр
що там не буду він афган їх замість
святі нових наукових матеріалів нових
методик викладання то мусом з 18 19
надходило підпорядковане супроводі наша
ідея мати ялинкою наша
а всього цивілізованого світу і
праведних караян кольору поля й у тому що
дитину і молодо люду уве 17 року в
травні як телицею з формованої ви на
ви на 10 тому мої бутовий вирішила ти ж
терей prophecy не пекла якісь проблеми
дуже багато великих міфів та наприклад
розповідати ось я акції у 18 особистому
бачите речі будуть shit is the queen моїх
417 особистому вигляді а ви за раз подавитись
вінчани на честь
річ із дітей ми на мага і ми з другим
а ти у складі усвяти
у нас що я лише місяць брати на
ринку проти для 18 річкових дітей
алізорро свани абсолютно незріло
навіть часто йдуть у вишлю про свиту і навіть
частоти колів будь я cuvee що у свиту
аби зараз знаходитесь в hd
у процесі навчання та цивілізований
sweet when i d владно шляхом cool їжу
18 роки
люди не треба дати дуже добрі повна
захочемо середнього світу а штрек ріжки так
ти пірсу професію курки і ось три
особисто профіль на старша школа 10 11 12
клас буду з прямого на ноти щоб дати
диким повну позику середнього кольору по
через академічний профіль можна
давати кути полон і ви вчення про край їх
предметів його туго тестів ступа вуз
обозу правий і сильним профілом з дубу ти
про крем повні за хворі середні свити
кваліфікаційного рубіт ніка
обидва молодшого спеціаліста і вичавлюєте
перша професію хочу сказати що в
розвідданих краї нах Європи
більше 5 сад і адже сотки в дітей віком і d
владні шляхи від ріму няшей старші
професії тамиші wanlima результаті як
соціальну подушку ми вже їхали пу
руках його над рамою to set у вас до
штормам
звучали ну його немає ремонту святого з
кущів на суму я хочу зняти всі ці
страхи
школа нового розпочато річкова українська
школа це буде з правдою ваза я пензлем
школою ми будемо в секунду льодово але над
своїм проти ти
майонезу розхвалю і якоб омах ти тенге
тим яки в чаті всієї школі і я їх колян
що змінить і ось тут нам треба на
пружину проти ти з вчителям і на
тонів за ним наших про програмних гей
черги житніх стандарті бушміну
стандарту fci ту ж серйозно справа його
названий будуть змінюватися владною для
нової української школи нині виникають з
дуже багато дискусії навколо так званих
наполегливу школу скільки dd централізація
влада великий не агромат почини ваше бо
чині міністерство щодо кольорових
сумних закладів
яко тамо і виду ватою себе початковою
процесі їх the mohicans у нього ти його
Тепер за всі сувої взяли ідея про
хлопцеві
по Польщі доказ прибудуть того що у
нас сільські території та миски
території зовсім різьблені доступ доярки
свої та світи з показувати результати за
нього
сільські гід та десятки розвивати менше
шанс із клас ти успішно за неї на
прикотили земних move тисячних приймати
їх так сам
чому так вигляд буває тому що в нас
менше і чапель кастильського населення та
дітей нас або окей кишки у завищується
the same
ти означає що кілька дітей там де
на прихід школі колись було 300 дітей
зараз моїм таки школи за раз компед і
seat гітою
я катя школою і першого 3 ст у коня і
там я старші класи, то вихід ще один в
чотири
фізику фізкультуру англійську мову та
що йшли вже 12 предмети ціни може бути я
кисло його святу і думу принцип для кейм
з вигляду йому її до і так уже проти душ
збагативши краї на
початкова школа там доходить маленька
біт і мої пляшки найбільші до місця
проживання дитину на тему проекту закону
просвіту в парламенті передача та ціна
адже так зла на школа 1 в 4 тут вона ж
їх шо хитрі маленькі дитинки нас чи їх
не можна в мову і в 6-річному
sam & rich нам побачити і про дим у 4 може
проїхати і читати їх дітей
червона діти старшого віку не можеш сторож
дати і відриву ти якісь знос вид очищення
через t
що ми хочемо з брехт і містеру боти в 4
фу маленькій малокомплектній школі ви
нас правді з проти праворуч дуб приниження
ревеню скілл це що ви хочемо дітей
старшого віку з цього хлопця школи та d
адже ти їх навчають або які зустрічаєте
роботу я до найбільшого слова будинку та ціни
розуміє і ціни унікальний процес
понесли поставити харчування що ми нас
правді хочемо труби ти я і до міністра
свиты в польшу черва зубів я за над бате
я думаю що мета і за далеким усі її
влади
про добро і я трясу свити дитину
то чоловік дружин та дітей навпроти дітей
знаходити школу за ради школи школи створ
вони за рада наших дітей і школи ви
вид побачити і націй захід дитині
і сьогодні їх що ми та con su ліду йому
ресурси та завзяті школа від школа куди
перевозяться гід з
інших населених пунктів особливі вагіт і
старші школи може також кити базові
школи з школа я cable 1 на я до моєї
кваліфікаційний склад у 4 кв я до моєї
кабінети та інші театри maids правде
крадіжок його почету я бачу один у пасік що
ми з його влада і відкривають форму
винна паса детектив у новий шкільний
автобус
а я хочу сказати що ми на далласі сот
мільйонів гривень на місці вона закупила
вежі в них автобусі ми на дав і 200
мільйонів гривень на пофарбований я
матеріально технічні бази завзятих скіл
і місць його влада мало до дати своїх гаїв
я хочу нога дати що в результаті
реформи децентралізації завдавши поспіху сич
не попер шепні 2016 урок у наді йшло на
23 мільярди гривень більше не за
аналогічний період ми нових уроку та ланцюга
гросе яким кути по стежці ти в
центральний бюджет або через переріс
підлив подарунки в за раз прийшли на місце
вай ривай важливий його щоб тигра читаєш
ви користувалася а на користь усвяти
і на користь підвищення яскравість його
почет і filth до їхніх дітей продовжити
тему про світло і вибув і пашем query онуком
українського центру оцінювання кістки
знань вам ту ж таки добра знайома
структура
як ви про командує ці падику сталося
навколо
скандал вже диво підне на результаті
вибуху про це дуже багато говорила і ту
ж
акти дно умовляв та й надали таки
могла статусі скільки і сама система
зона мало ви корана ти круп chill
систему свити мерзотники я хочеш тварюка
десь система за неї нас правдиві
годувала широку масштабну корупцію та
при у ступі до вищих початкових закритої
там ще колими зростання починало
1 рубль від цієї системи 2000 іншому 2003
роті на рейтингові факультети
пташечками могла пролетити і пск барабу
лади кілька університетів століття і малий
влада над остигання для того, щоб
забезпечити і прозорець штуку та голоду
живота skype такі вікі говорилося що
ціни за проти України
на і більше 20 років тому що в тему
сидити дуже велика кіль кисть
очей нації хорошої та взятки анімація з
грубими та пісня виробник чим мало
людей повернутися до озвученої бачіли
перших та інших хитро цих і сьогодні
дуже багато дітей вступаючи без міяко їх
обидва рифи в умбрії не вище за
скарби живлення в тому що система затиску та
у розриві нести
і таким різним місцям було б з
останнього
база даних за результатом його тіні
вання і я обожнюю що ти що сталося і
щоб його 5 хв і але яка краса не
результаті за грошима прокуратури
відразу мило що в парі мене не сотнями
тисяч 6 ніки був і проведення свої душі
моїй сумці відсотка чи для нас важливого
шкіра на дітей на тому що бутика фільмі
на результат означає що заходить на
бюджет не той, хто нас правді вступаємо а
то і хто нас правді мо провідний результат
за дружину споживаючи на бюджет цього прийому
доручається сум його право там у для
нас дуже важливо ще прослідування
булатова айдану до кінця і ми water млн
горішки правди чи результати і я
заперечується що суддя суддя правда чи
результат али
харчування в тому що в бутіку
насправді технології треба інвестувати
зон ще не чути зовсім не я навіть
довга година на цю фінансувалася
наприклад зарплата у програмісті столітті та
проти в центрі стану було дві з
половиною тисячі гривень але з одразу мило
що c і смішна зарубає на плато для
програміста та кай
проти я в такому центрі я покараю що c
давало право заміні у цій результати
all its фрс нас памуккале по Деви Тася
правді у vici
що я що таки в розриві системи по ви
не їх на лижному члені фінансово
забезпечує забезпечу так само не було
зроблено системи захисту внаслідок століття
так вже я дошку що ви сьогодні я можу
завжди спокійний ситуації змінена тому
що нас тебе ситуація з пану колу теппер
по бенкету рити систему за христу бази
даних українського центру оцінювання
кущі та квіти
підняті за зарубану плату противником
українського центру оцінювання я гарна
святі лисиці вигляд була озвучена душа
високу ціну і зараз ми можемо брухт
кайдо т.к. ти смітиш і не суду
тому що на моїй переконань кава за
раз на приклад говорити про те, що треба
вершині ось це їх snapchat через піски
абсолютного генеральна прокуратура
зраду і результат нас правді cyma та
буде побачено у судді
поки не моє рішення суду у нас немає і
причин відра холод і з їх студенти та
вищим рішенням суду можна буду руку і
тайяки здалеку від містера ти не ви знову
ще одна актуальна проблема натиснули у нас
завищується термін у rixos забезпечення та
ін учнем і
єдиного за 1 до дози часто нашим бочкам
доводьте куб увата педро ччанак і різьблених
автора в різьблених в данину який я в тему на
плівку політика міністерства голки
наріжте
українській дід ю сі будуть запас почину
підручником їжі та віку наскільки
хіральну сьогодні
ви знаєте що ми новому року guf
проведений такий експеримент з
децентралізації закупили піт ручники та
фактичного міністерство про святі наук
і закупівлі більше половини підручника в
затримавши не кошти rest у кішки виталина
місця
видом і на місці і на місцях малюк
петрушки до дати з їх кішки
алеях результат місця вірної влади
питали дуже туризму і у нас на
прикатки області д на 90 адже сотки в
забезпеченні вже закупила підручника та
для четвертих самих classic черневицький
області наприклад тут на 75 сотки в
забезпеченні закупили четверті суми
класі в дикі райони з членами запитували
на закуп ні такі області деш кенеша
ситуації та для маніяка для міністра батька
і урок job відразу мід і отрута що ми ж
побачимося Петро вчений клей требор обід
з
централізовані закупив чи я не бачу
меншого виходу ми взяли на себе
централізовано закупили 8 класу та за
раз труби обличчя в годину ну все підручнику
для 8 клас вже ставити сотні на іншого
не і доїжджаючи до споживача в області я
знаю як мене поінформували щоб
Чернівецькій області на даний час до
замок їжі сядь адже сотки
і друг ніки з шкірним німці архів з
буде руста ти для 8-го класу
там за забезпечення з підручником і
буди
ми на хвалю і які з їхнього підручника
цьому нам треба за раз шукаємо переконати
їжу самому процесу вирубаний я спить
ручника проведення конкурсу на підручник
через купе влити всього підручника тут я
багата проблем і від за розписка початку
нового початкову руку займемося прицільно
новим становищем про підручник і ми б
ви не прийнятої для себе 100 точні
рішення який magix приємні заростання я
кістки початкової та літератури
у нас українці дошкільного світла на жаль
йому сама
ви знати це ще далеко вона сидить і
сьогодні ви яких місцях мати може
вивести вранці від і дошкільного світла б
саме в місці ви в черні вся
взяв долею і відкрити нвк на волосині
бар жіночий такі комплекси на вашу
думку виконай комплексах то мої буду
ват їх томи і фінансово ти тому що
нація потрібно нічим або кошти і ваші
baci нею від міністра сьогодні мій будь
нього
українського дошкільного вишивання дітей
і ви вирішення проблеми із забезпечення
дітей духовне та про святу
мерзотники адушкіна вас вигляд це вже
потрібно його всім і світи
йдуть шляхом за носіння у віку дітей
коливан і маєчка стежки адже ти вас не
систему і їжу стеження ки здаюсь що
дошкільного свято прямо з великі
відразу успішніше state in і чому школі
там у шкіра на дитину сміття по стежці ти в
душі його свиту харчування коли та кронштадті
було за найму старих років вона кілька
заспіваною сьогодні у нас по Україні не ви
випадку між шків не у свиті і це
криголам з будинку графічні щури коли
закривала і продавав і дужки не за клади
ізар основним не можна повторити і
загинули і за дрібною з нашими школами та
офісі на технічному та початковому за
скарбом та
то ми б моєму душарі тельно думає і я
як заарештовують та переміщення на
приклад скілл які ви змінюються і від
така історія куліїв приймеш лінії школи
виділених приміщеннях ми рубати приховуємо
пеклі шкіль не групи з я grass рецепт на
ви вирішите, щоб ми розлютили кільки
суміш дужки чи
і при тому ефективно викури 100 вивал і
будемо стегна
то моя душа харчуються за крему у
чернівцях ми моєму тут ситуацію cool та
на 100 місць у душкина із закладок
претендуючи 147 дітей, і тут я реально
проблема збила не вниз я обожнюю що c
правильно кули ти камера я подекуди
взяли каденс пріоритет
збив якийсь кістки mist адушкін їх
закладок
вищого світла на буковині у цій взяла
долею та відкриття нового корпусу
чернева текау національного університету
ная кубачи ковані буде нестиковок дощок
іншого артиста Івана про фінансово
у ряду
міністерством також ви взяв у частиною
церемонії присвячений а паша курників черні
ваську національного університету у кого
з душевних вдалих коли meal та
сьогодні то з цього активного говорити про
ітані я реформи вищої просвіти
у контексті про бідний мене вищих
початкових заплативши разу назвати nabucco
ви неосяжна нічого не війська
національному університету буквою sky
фінансової академії вашої підлеглої
будні та вищої про світіно сьогодні
і і ким ву на мої ніби і четвірка настя
таких початкових закладі повік
Чернівецький національний університет
модеми оптом і до миска тримаючи нам вдало
коли мене класичних таких буде ось
потрібна історії
ось я хотіла побути розкачати випробування
владного бідно невеликих початкових
заході б ви але навіть розливати спраги
потрібно суви поставити їм це завдання
вам ці рогом у від для mali ми е
завжди очевидно
зрощення кістки надішлю його свити ось
науку три дні шакали ваша дітей на
вступаючи до вищого початкового закладу
ви їх бачка і могли шляхи в попелі не що
тут у тілі вищому початковому заході
ви на відриваючи довідки я киснеш його
свиту
мова-то з інструментами cool і у нас ви за
годину на кисть грибних вищих так шалених
закладі якин та майк міжнародних
програм я кіно та інтеграла його світло не
європейський простер століття їх мискою aquis
викладання та fi
закладає дасть від нього ресурсу, а я
хочу удачі
так вже повернуть його шоу можу що цілу
особисто
ступ на компанія мало механізм розпаду
державного за мовляв і не так і що
часті на дітей окей акімат вибивали за
її
фактично несли міс податкова та
державного за блискавка овочі початкові
закладок та іван та прибирали
топ то ви ще навчальний заклад і могла
уникнути якщо опція тримаючи на замовлення
на 25500
та вік що піт 70 та geht es вийшли ми
балом через нього щось чується справило
що гарна навчальний заклад і набрав
і без дітей набряки хижак і мені довіряють
абітурієнти активні даєте окисні почти
малі менше держави замовлення і я пари
канону що ми моєму концентрату ресурси
у крадіжок їх ви шахнів чайних закладок і
шукай ви ще почали закладати на спокій
думає і яскравим вимовляючи до крашкову
там ще з фарбую я доступ так я
найтіснішу святих них студенти я розумію
про таксі ви часто виступає
адміністрація тіло вищого початкового за
кладуть бактус був ректором не
переставайте ректорові так може
виступати ви кладу чипований часто
побоюється конкуренції з викладками шамів
крадіжок йому вищого початкового закладу
а так зараз потрібно конкуренція поінти
ми імпланту йому закон право ще свиту
нові закони типів прийнятий відразу після
революції видно стіни Всевишній
навчальний заклад та за раз викладати
положення цього закону, наприклад
дві треті початкової години
травня стану ти курси за вибору топ та
що це означає що студент мої права
брат і
той курс як і йому подібне з і в нас
його ще почали закладати і також
проти лайк і до
імплементації закону право свиту а
і такі кити порубав і дати і промінь asus і
тому що струми
пекло тачан при обамі з собою конкур
вати їм треба за правду називає курс
за це кого ти шукаєш загони, щоб студенти
прибрав і ціль курс так само сьогодні
забив білшина буває значення
програми з 2 інших дипломів
чоловіки весь студентам виїжджати та
насаджування
і б почати і china част кого і навчання
у межах партнерства між університетами
і
зацем знайдуть не те що сьогодні про
святого на залишається пак і пиши
глобальної особливо вище про свято
тому ми не здається що за раз потрібного
борід і seo не заїкаюсь такі свої місця
окулярів
інтереси aus виглядом лего ти що над лист
курорт же немає цілісності абітурієнтів
не розумних не прийдіть про бідного тис і
кришитися еру б ти добру вільну
верхову чиї інтереси всіх сходи ви
кладу ніж ніш руб це c nobbut та пити
штампованим і вже зверху тому сьогодні я
вийшла за клікаю всіх наших вікторій у
системі вище свити особливо його вороги він ах
створе вати тугіше niva сільський
регіональні центри
hайти буду об'єктна університеті
а леван в результаті об'єктну між бою базу
hurtta рідкий свою
матеріально-технічну базу і може
забезпечити цієї ти я кислий процес
окладу та розмови тобто так само
couture не васька та національні нього
завдання на core acer німецьку
національному університету з університетом
по 1 входить до топ-10 університету
україни та
ціль університети gras пройти системі в
ступу cool & guide та могли принести ідуть
від кави місця державної за молла не до
університету
ігрос від риму в змішання державного
замовлення але with mine вбиті інших
регіональному університеті столітті натиснули і
я була сильно так і ми авторитетним і
для своїх абітурієнт лабуде вниз твоя
панування таких подібних корпусів
рахунок міністерства таким принципом
позначається фінансово ні отрути прикладу c
повішені за рахунок міністерства
міністерстві про святі науки моєї
жадібних капітальних ви дотки али я хочу
на клопотання що метою торговий корпус
університету розгойдав у своє загиблий
у дев'яносто першому уроці тобто venger
вісник незалежності
за зараз туди було вклади, але дуже
багато грушей я хочу визнає а їх усі
їжу в губу twin пачино і руїну ватою
ставити того що вінс тобто порожнім і
це було то ситуацій акули не orchid але
голос тут немає і якісь у порядку в
льне завершу в завершували не роботою і
на c потрібно булави робить від йдуть від
кору кішки щоб не пропав і в мережі кошт
і які будуть вклади не продовжиш
mogatec руки
дугу будинку тіла корпусу крем того
вимагав хватай століття їх умовах почалася
вона стрибає мій буде не вчить або
психолога соціолога яких momax на ходу
вася комп'ютер не наукою так то он з
довідки у ставку вже багатих руки
втиснулася вона таких плашках, що води
zara заслуговує на чат і сам
початковому іншому корпусі я б випадково
тихіше lasik що ​​у нас більше університеті
у могли бути приховані своєму вина вчорне
корпус та особливо засланих університеті
в університеті
які сьогодні інтеру яйця в європейський
us with не просто будьте університети та
агрос виявити право плану українців у
око не університети
вона ж торг на new їх до польші диво
інших краєм і там уми затікала не в
розвитку таких сильних регіональних
що я хотіла б туди ти над
чи винною
над литого що в нас такі ресурси
відволікається на оборону країни C5
сотки ВВП
булла все-таки знайди нам пішли весь
давай сорому шляху а ціль корпус
університету та думу для мене це ви краще
озноб агія
c знак яко і ми посилаємо у врагу
протащу ревний зуб інакше розвитку
топ то ідея ворога польова в тому, щоб з
др і мати рожевий топ в Україні щоб fi
наші ресурси і йшли на оборону здати
немає алли ми крутимо в вимагають і другим
інакше наша на заручницях bourgogne від шиї
ви бачили все-таки яйця та ризиковий парад
я крики шити нас ми великим зовсім нішу
армію зовсім менших людей шляхів армії
людей довідник патріотів захисники та
розум стем для нас важливі ви мені цю троянду
книгу людського потенціалу через систему
святі у що я головне в краї не і що
буду україну своя грома gaining їй
україни та
новий корпус університету cx impale що
свято розвивається і краї народ вдови та
продовжують вашу тему щось наших а
барон тереке сьогодні обороняти на сході
наша держава наша на заручниць наш
україну з чудо навчання їхніх дітей
одно ваза мовляв вони і до тут політика
міністерства і я кобудо політика у
подалі му для того, щоб сидить і мале
дно святої доступу на і порізів мета у
нас читку ви означає на ситуація з
приводу дітей
бочки бочку яких dance party вче
бутіка ситуації та до тусується zara були
че
того що хто з бочки вмер вид пара
нині від риму нового the city guide і
будуть забезпечити мід самодержавного за
блискавка я вчилася кури коштує 6 вашими
ferrum за предмети всіх що ми можемо
плутати ситуацією що хто з баки в
заглянула і - забезпечив і дитину
містер державного за блискавками щоб вона
не змогла в ступи ти на бюджет
вступила щоб тьмяно лазаньї вступила на
мовчання за контрактом ми чудово розуміємо
йому ситуацію цифру ден і ми Петро і моєму
цілі дітей
c процедура за раз вище навчальний
заклад і вибралася в нехай так і дітей
у якої їх потрібно їх місія
державного за блискавка та 1 вересня та в
залі
ми в міністерстві про святих продавця їх
гнів robomow переріс зрозумів за ложки
державного замовлення
і самці за ложки державної за мол нині
з прямого не владно наки категорії
громадян
які ви значення законом і україни я
категорії що моя темрява ти місця
державного за мовляв вони забиті сиру
наприклад
може but i шийок з України ситуації
типу в'язання з дітьми-інвалідами
зараз збере його вид університету в мережі
Заявка на це що університети на та кращому
знаю кіоко дитину принесла даних
документи та університети нам падав і
в'ють свої
ініціативніше листи з приводами здійснено
замок нанівець розуму і що що я хтось
д'алема з у ниви і ванної вигляд вивів і
однозначно вимиє ой ти в тій
університети dv вступила на контракт та
адже сови університету
нам подають заявку до міністерства усвяти
олег що ви в університеті вранці і це
якин лист не перепони тилу цілує і прямо
на гарячу лінію міністерство вас вигляд і
навчити нас
крим нас глечик на основі спеціально the
cask ринку є тут нижньої піт крісло не
про те він голий
для такої категорії абітурієнт
щипанова в диня починаючи з нового
початкового руку за знаючи з мін і
концепт виплати стипендій для студентів
чим за мовляв вони таки багато води дня
є а називаючи прикрасою для студентів
та мотивації та стимулювання для того
щоб гарно ни
умов валу матеріал а хто ситця
називаючи просто економію бюджетних кішки
знає і але ми не буду ж хотілося
сигналу свиту виділялася з 7 адже сотки
ввп
як ми і написали у проекті закону право
свиту
і я обожнюю що кішка на асв тупо ви не
буде і обов'язково засміє джині
але ми живемо у наших реаліях
ми живі і фінансовий муфтій економічніший
ситуації до я сьогодні і ми ж у яму
ситуації cool і був і чесно кільки з
ресурси відволікаєте на оборону здати
скручені завитки ролики е.і.
ми не можемо ось цієї біш і ніш нас є
дусі дні частими я не хочу так уже
крісло ти що весь голос реформа
децентралізації і ми продали душі
значний ресурс на місці я вже говорила
про 23 мільярди
так і таких парі - ми новим роком
Запоріжжя залучити і трохи пак і не
поспішає і vici і там у неї немає ні куди
перевитраті впав на важливий тому що
завантажуваної духовної дружини голови що
змінила з державного бюджету вона там
сам він і з'явиться
вину прийшов бюджет і наша гривня і ціл
означає що за це травня типу в накладення
праворуч стипендій
сьогодні ситуація у нас така oriental на
75 сотки в дітей віком по Україні
я хизується на бюджеті ранку йому
іт-стратегії тести з гео становить 3
тобто і 800 гривень по росич на
студенти вищих початкових за кліки
3 4 ременя кредит від
і студенти у нас їй різанини та студенти я
піцу стипендію викачають
за 34 походи біля кафе і є студенти
які і q але блять і живуть ці сходи та
у продажі місяці і тепер харчування
маленько щаблем категорії яки ясна
зажадають такої та пити ринку guide &
yaki душа добрих годинник та детальки сьогодні
у вимагає стипендію мою 4-ку
ми поважаємо і штаму ебут iso 100 і
матковий petit стипендії ви не будь
ти в мотивований цих то в чаті добрий
швидше ук це перше положення топ the
best trick подруги
прерогатива повинна надавати з цим
дітям у яка їх складним це реально
стаєш
топ тобто суті вони степ індійці мало
за вас печінки та гід та сиру ти ми на та за
світанку стипендії олійник що ми
говоримо про академічну стипендію то обидва
за особливі успіхи в на вч обидва ці може
бути жердина і пмдр
за успіхи в на вч вони і крем того
складні матеріальної стаєш коли
згодні гіти ну ось уявити собі батьківщину
в 4 столітті дитинка поїхала на в чат і себе
у праведний навчальний заклад тому що
менше місця wana wana отримала дуже
високий показаних через зовнішній
незалежного оцінювання ви навпроти це
таланову це а краще можуть он і в крим
а ти диво ти ну в тому разом за щаблем
800 гривою я до речі дитину теж добрих
jets і так ipad рибу та таке пити ринку
таги нам треба дума той можна його та його
рота пе-2 щити трахкати у стипендії та за
раз ми продаємо націю концепції і це
дуже важко і діалог я ви знаю з
міністерством фінансів та крему та запалили
своєї вежі з дроту стипендії
а не секрет що ми пиши на такому
популістичний шляхом сини степів м і
великих кошиках повз і таке вухо плані
я китай стипендіями чи ми по ви не
обізнані що за такого низького рівня
жити а в краї не ви мусом і Петро і Метт
і наших студентів думи за 1 сука йому отрута
у тих світах того бюджету на ці ми можемо
розруху висновок і Петро i mat інший крадіжок тих
і питирима тих хто найбільшої вимагай
просту частину на воду випробую вас ще
про профтех до скиту в контексті
децентралізації як реформами з його
самоврядування передача ще ті початкові
за скарбом а youtube ремонт та
titled реальних громади на 4 то реван з
знаходите олайне для ковані сократом
сюди зараз таван ес помічники у вас
рубає і полагоди ваше міністерство що
думай буде його просто їх освіта
скільки чорна бити взяті статистику на
ринку проти сьогодні рубає нині
prophecy все-таки завищуються
досвіді профі сильно технічного свято з
мабуть на і пак краще харчування до я за
раз ми не було цих міністрів того, що я
обожнюю було б правильним рішення про
передачі прав та сильно технічні його
свиті повністю нами стовпа знову
значення чуму тому що темою став
обласного значення дуже різьбленими за
своїми доходами та їм маленькими 100
обласного значення для довгих
наприклад voy dod кіно про луну свиту
може становити ти більше 30 адже сотки в
їхнього бюджету та їхню
видати коли та частими бюджету та cs
сильно навантаження на них не бюджет і
тут ми зараз треба ловити
уряду самі на такі місця обласного
значення допомогу а самої спочатку було
виділено 500 мільйонів гривень
забарвлення в лідку ми виділив японок 90
мільйонів гривень алея на 2017 рік
вчимо вас мін цієї принципала ситуацій
самій парі та ти професіонал технічного
свиту на обласні ривай передати
у середню субвенцію you with держави нас
дубу
я за хворі середні усвяти тому що там
і гід і які розум спав і сильну
святу забуваєте загальна середня
клінтону ми в диму змін і
протащим у нас було державне замовлення
на професії загальна національного
значення тому що, наприклад, я пропустила
технічніше почали закладати та готувати
за професіями для неї днів та області
самі області далі області їх що
захоче і пройдуть до такої з пильні з
води може місцям виліпимо переда ти
часто і ну професіонал технічних
початкових закладі тому що інакше був
ці місця у криму до вени чесні ресурс
на місці
9 і випив руку так і такого 23
мільярди по Україні до бюджету професій
але технічні якщо ти нарік становить 5,7
мільярда
топ то ви розуміє і що ти значиш але
менше ніш нас правді відривав ідуть від
кого ресурсу то мудаки миски голови геть
ікри блять душі you call та розповідають
що їм так ваш q іван і не хоче
фінансово татю професіонал технічно us
with у нас правді е1 такі мер на
накази бьякуго земну палиця дискусія я
коен і фінансово профі дуже технічний
за клади зарплату шалені
а причому у мам на казначейського муру
хунг у гаю hs 300 мільйонів гривень
кримів на депозитах такого не може бути
ресурси і дмуть з повною повагою і це
музло чайна нам ті урок та вимагав hugo
ttt uk бюджетному кодексі якоюсь буде і
у 2017 уроки та прийняті рішення
ми ухвалили державні рішення про
самоуправління
і децентралізацію в краї чи то громада
які беруть на собі
ресурс і відсікаються і ресурс по ви
тут повз ти так вже мабуть свій
йдуть від кави повної дружини
вам душа добрий знаємо і проблеми, а світло
і в
і пройшли доз ці борги шлях битви
хапали від директора департаменту
голови комітету Верховної Ради Міністра
усвяти
і науки ваші boccia до сьогодні
і за рахунок чого можна пофарбувати і я
кисть з вигляду і тому що ми сьогодні з
вами говорили про тепла які сьогодні
робот міністерство ківи ниткою це для
щоб матеріальну для товщі ніж
методично пофарбуй це початковий процес
звідси сцен нам яскравістю світи якісь ви
на буду і буду ити багатий move шини can i
take the c траві бути новий з mist
якщо мати but in awe методик і
викладання та ключі та нові us with
nice і пологів про ключові ключові я
вчитель тому що секція будди проти
ти і круті письменник кайту гекони буду
ви проходите через вчителі і новий з
місць та нові методики викладання та
менше засовувати нові технології
навчання
і c на бейсболі краще за проблему
ми вже я сьогодні з вами тур їздили по
ній можна говорити і дуже багато ми
вимагаємо перевищення кваліфікації в
читацьких кадрів ми вимагатимемо
зростання їх мотивації та клімат їх
коло і в які ви писання в кінноту
крима
бідняки про яких несіть плюс у вані та
підрив несіть і плямі саня ремені оплати
проти перевищується ви могли до
кваліфікації в 4 за одного боку ми в
в'язницю проект закону право свиту про
плану та масштаб 4 малий свободу вибору
перевищення кваліфікації базар османи
мучити раз на п'ять руки і ти на
конкретний курс до інституту писав
диплом та його почти
олег порицаем з'явилася боготуру травневих
організацій
найвищих початкових зате геїв і кидають
суден і тренінги для 4 в
спеціалізований на котлет проц
його ти з дітьми з особливими ми вимагатимемо
обаяти проц його ти в інтернет активними
методи коліно втягни
нам потрібно шепчі тільцями хабера ти а
потім суди за раху-це є перевищення
кваліфікації з передачі та законом так
самця та проект закону право кольору
передача і так звана добра фея
сертифікацію в 4
я називаю з павуком вогники в його реформах
свити
що таке дібровина сертифікації цикли в
4 крем від і стаття кого не проходити 1 5
руки може добре видно пити на сонячну
сертифікацію центру поправити це стільця
не про тобто. криві вичитував агеїв
інтерактивними методиками ці цибулею
патент не знову назви че ти розумієш
там впали гри форма про святі що ти
можеш привнести цей
я китає ви кори стоїш проціону методики
та навчальний матеріали
там також травня ворогів і тобто досвід його
не та колег 4 у бочки
які будуть давати і вигляд звук і про роботу
цілих чотири та таги так і в 4 за
результатом успішного проходження
сертифікації можна трьома т29 садками на
два ходи заруба ні плати ct чіп новому
законі акрил і жити у парламенті та чека
і я перуку він вона що в 4 довідки
руфери форми в читай та гривні до
початкового закладу, тому що велика
група людей які mightst від та лідерами
реформ церкви реван та кленів чайних
закладі
тому що він уже часто їх розлитий
таких через воску століття майки за
забезпечення у криму не застосування що
ппу в ремонт ще була створена
начальниці пологів шукай сьогодні наші
дари хто вирішив чоловік і його конова ти тут
функцію тлф розуміє but i лідером та
своїх колективі он і травня тьму ти висновок
зі своїх 4
чи вмінням це до штопка час буде
заходу ти в учительську школу в 4
не шкодувала сядуть одному проти що саме
ви стати я йду нові зарплати crushei він
і не може собі куб і ти витку видно ой
ах для того, чим цю дачну літературу
ось для того, щоб ти перед світлими очима
дітей with pu видному вигляди хули на
буде вмовляти і між бою, але мабуть
the duck та викладання коливань та будуть
ділити і самим собою доз видом колибу
робити а горизонтально us with не
комунікації там у що цівка збувається
заразу школах Фінляндії
цілі збувається у школах у праведних
системах усвяти
і я гадаю так вину за раз звучіть
мережива мрія
alloy fps на наших що ми всі звіти
музу силь
і як що у нас будуть державна kioki
розуміють що us with a cd частини на
національні bespeco мого скроні вода
зігни емоції і брей я вам дякую за
розмелювання pro roller і форма світиться
так вже про концепцію нові українські
школи сьогодні нам студії розправила
міністру світою наукою України або
агранович я вам de oca через розмелювання
дяку це для ночей зате рахунок було сяду
за зустрічі в ефірі
коробка